غرف نوم وغرفة معيشة ومطبخ مفتوح ،
لدينا خزانات تخزين منخفضة ،
إنه منزل مثل أي منزل آخر
أو ليس تمامًا ،
لذا فنحن الآن في
بداية خط الإنتاج
ما يجعله متميزًا هو أنه تم
تشييده على بعد كيلومترات في منزل
المصنع وتم تجميعه في الموقع في غضون
أسابيع
، يطلق عليه اسم وحدات الإسكان المعياري ، وهو
يأخذ بالفعل عناصر العمل من
موقع البناء ويقومون
بتصنيعها في بيئة خاضعة للرقابة
خارج الموقع ،
وهي شركة وحدات سكنية
تأسست في دبي في عام 2020.
الفكرة وراء الرابط هي توفير
حل سكني حيث يوجد حاليًا حل
من الحشوات إلى الطبقات الخارجية ،
يبدو الحفر هنا مختلفًا بعض
الشيء ، يشبه خط الإنتاج عندما ينتهي
العمل على هذه الوحدة المعينة ،
يتم فهرسة كل شيء إلى
محطة العمل التالية كلها في  كل الفكرة
هي توفير الوقت ،
لا يبدو أن صناعة البناء قادرة على الحصول على مستويات
الكفاءة التي تحتاجها  لجعل نفسها
مستدامة اعتمادًا على المشروع ،
تقدر شركة linc أنها يمكن أن توفر منازل
تصل إلى 40 بشكل
أسرع من الطريقة التقليدية
بمجرد أن تصبح جاهزة ، يمكن
شحن المنازل المعيارية وتجميعها في أي مكان في
العالم ، ويمكن أن يكون هذا جزءًا من
حل لمشكلة عالمية
موحدة  تقدر الدول أن 40 في
المائة من سكان العالم
سيحتاجون إلى الحصول على سكن ملائم بحلول عام
2030. تتطلع لينك للبدء في
المساعدة في توفير هذا الطلب من خلال شركات
الشحن العام المقبل إلى المملكة المتحدة ،
لذلك نظرنا إلى سوق المملكة المتحدة ويسعى سوق المملكة المتحدة
جاهدًا إلى  تسليم 300000
منزل سنويًا ، فهي توفر حاليًا
حوالي 150000 منزل سنويًا ، ونعتقد
أن الوحدات النمطية توفر إجابة
لسد الفجوة بين ما يريدون
القيام به وما يحتاجون إلى القيام به
، وتأمل الشركة أيضًا في تسليم منازل
أقرب بكثير من ذلك  في موطنها
الأصلي ، ولكن من غير المحتمل أن نرى
وحدات برج خليفة في المستقبل ، يتمتع
البناء بطبيعته بالكثير من
الذوق في تصميمه.
تصنيع
الصناديق الفولاذية المستطيلة التي لها مكان
ويمكن دمجها ويمكن
تصنيعها لتبدو رائعة ولكنها لن
تحل جميع المشكلات ،
لذلك لا يزال هناك مجال للنمو ولكن
مع شحن الوحدات الأولى للرابط في العام المقبل
إذا كنت تبحث عن  تصميم بسيط وسريع
لمنزل من دبي يمكن أن يكون
خيارًا لمنزلك المستقبلي
Eleni Jacquard CNN Dubai